Christian woman hacia Vivi had spent
eight years on death row in Pakistan
after being convicted of blasphemy she
was finally acquitted on appeal this
month as if eight years wasn't enough
her acquittal sparked violent protests
by thousands of fundamentalists
demanding her head her lawyer has now
fled Pakistan in fear of his own life
BB's husband said he too fears for his
family's safety and has asked Teresa
made to grant them asylum Boris Johnson
has written to cabinet ministers with
the same request so far Asylum hasn't
been offered it is alleged that the UK
has stopped short of making this offer
because her move to the UK would cause
unrest among British Muslims and would
also pose a security threat to our
embassies abroad now even a red tape
rejection would be easier for me to
stomach than the allegation that our
Asylum system cowers in the face of a
fanatical mob isn't the system meant for
the exact opposite to provide sanctuary
to those being hounded by such fanatics
such appeasement surely renders our
Asylum system no longer fit for purpose
I completely agree with you
not in relation to asylum in the UK but
I completely agree with you in terms of
just how horrific a CBeebies
circumstances are my only issue with
what you're saying is she's been offered
asylum in Spain and in France but for
whatever reason her husband is saying
that he would rather asylum in the UK
and that's reportedly of course we don't
know cause he only what I don't
understand is why aren't those two good
options because she's the main thing is
to actually get the Pakistanis to agree
to allow her to leave the country of
course that which is what the focus
should be on because she has two places
that she can go to for that that is that
that would be the main thing definitely
is to get her out safely first of course
just as a recap it's so dangerous in
Pakistan that the governor of the the
former now governor the late governor of
the most powerful province Punjab when
simply campaigning for a reform in the
law that had her convicted for so-called
blasphemy was murdered by his own
bodyguard her own lawyer has fled the
country it is that dangerous we've got
to get her out of the country first and
most is done so you're the mayor
allegation is and that they'll be honest
yeah but in answer to your to your
question June I think my main concern
isn't that she wasn't granted asylum in
Britain though that is a concern of mine
my main concern are the reasons given
and I don't think it I don't think it
sets a good precedent to start refusing
asylum applications based upon what we
fear the people from whom that person is
seeking refuge might do because for me
that's the purpose may actually had to
say on this our primary concern is for
the safety and security of our Co BB and
and her family we want to see a swift
revenue resolution of the situation
obviously there's an issue for the
government and courts in Pakistan and
the Prime Minister Imran Khan has
publicly supported the Supreme Court and
promised to uphold the rule of law while
providing continued protection for a
CFPB but a number of countries are in
discussion about providing a safe
destination for her once the legal
process is complete I'm sure the house
I'm sure the house will understand given
the sensitivity of this case it wouldn't
be right to comment on the details of
those proposals at this stage but we
remain in close contact with
international partners to ensure us
uv-vis long term safety and her
interests so there you have it so
international partners have got together
and have decided that the best option is
France and Spain well that's where I
think the reasons that are being
reported by the British Pakistani
Christian Association as to why Britain
wasn't an option on the table are what
worried me and I say that I think
actually if we start saying that we're
not going to grant asylum because we
fear the reaction of those from whom
refuge is sought we're pretty much
turning the asylum system on its head so
if we make it not not about this
particular lady or her family and we
pick up on your point and we're saying
that actually there is people raising
that there's a concert and do you think
that's a legitimate well is it is likely
to be the case that fanatics
would like to retaliate against anybody
that defends a skier baby they've
already killed the Governor of Punjab so
that's you're in this yes even in this
country in Glasgow we had a shopkeeper
that was murdered by a by a Muslim
fundamentalist fanatic because he
happens to be from a different sect for
me is it legitimate to accuse a co Bibi
of blasphemy when as I understand it she
is a Christian as a Christian farm
worker who simply drank out of a bucket
used by Muslims and then said well I am
a Christian so I'm not actually didn't
actually say anything and it's I think
unbelievably hard and regrettable that
the president Imran Khan has been in
office for hundred days who's used the
very fanatical religious base has not
come out and stood up for this woman
okay can I hit can be just hear from the
head of the Pakistani were in Wilson
Chaudhary who who leads the Pakistan
Christian Association within minecon I
don't I'm not sure how confident I am
that he has the appetite for change and
not only because of the threat of danger
to himself but also because he has quite
openly declared great support for the
bus terminals these draconian medieval
laws are being used as a tool for
persecution how any government leader
can can claim that they need to be
espoused and championed by the populace
if beggars belief scandal this
modernizing so-called modernizing
playboy actually used their very further
that expressions not just a Serb BB in
her family but actually anyone who tries
to protect her you know but you know
you're saying about Spain and France for
me it's not something that should be
passed around like a hot potato it's
yours it's yours it's yours it's
something we should be saying right get
India love quick let's say let's sort
this out let's get you out of there
let's get you out harm's way and let's
save you and that's what I was about and
I don't care if mr. so-and-so ever
there's going to be off and I don't care
if you're gonna come after me cuz you're
doing wrong and I'm doing right and
that's it let's remember again to back
you up there on that point let's
remember that this country gave Malala
yousufzai asylum
Amanda waswas also shot in the Taliban
school attack gave him asylum and we're
incredibly proud that those two are now
campaigners and prominent you know
activists on this stuff I'm allowed as
an Oxford
I think they end up becoming people that
this country becomes incredibly proud
Malala foundation campaigns for women's
education throughout the Muslim world
because I really strongly feel that
we've got a situation where as a country
then whether officially or not you've
got people saying that actually we can't
accept this lady in the family in
because she's ultimately going to be on
safe from fanatics from Islamist
fanatics or whatever the correct term
terminology is but then if people start
trying to have those conversations about
how do we resolve that situation you're
immediately branded Islamophobic so how
what do we do about this scenario that
you're describing because I think it is
wholly unacceptable that you would have
people in this country that would want
to kill or hurt somebody else just
because they don't agree with their
religion I think that is a despicable
how do we fix that as you know Michelle
this is part of what I try and do and
after the Charlie Hebdo attacks back to
your point about the fact that it could
happen here yes after the Charlie Hebdo
attacks when surveyed I think it was
roughly a quarter of British Muslims
said that they sympathized with the
attackers who murdered those people at
the Charlie Hebdo offices for blasphemy
it was just around 26% so it there is a
problem and when you say what do we do
how do we speak about it of course when
I speak about it even as a born and
raised Muslim I've been labeled as an
anti Muslim extremist and I had to then
sue people and win in a case of
defamation for that so it is incredibly
difficult to have a rational rational
and reasonable conversation around that
around this but the only thing we can do
is let the facts guide us those survey
results are out there the polls are out
there led by facts have an intelligent
and reasonable conversation about this
until we end up moving the debate
forward I think it is the only option we
shouldn't allow that censure to prevent
us from having this conversation
yeah but prevented from the converse
having the conversation we often are and
for me that is one of the core problems